hello everyone I thought I wouldn't have
enough time to do another video today
but as it turns out I finished my work
earlier so I decided to show you the
game it's a clash of superpowers
actually a world number two against
world number three are a nun versus
mommy Gareth and it's quite a game it
was played in round six of the European
team Chess Championship and I'm not
showing you this game because of how
well our an unwanted I'm showing you
because how great mommy they are have
lost but you'll see what I mean
mommy Jared definitely decided to give
us an interesting game to check out so
lemon has the white pieces and he plays
c4 we have c5 so the English opening
Knight to f3 Knight to c6 Knight to c3
g6 g3 Bishop to g7 Bishop to g2 again
the ultra symmetrical variation d6 11
castles east six III Knight G to e7 d4
mama dir of castles rook to e1 Knight to
f5 now and d5e capture Sun d5 Knight
captures on d5 and Knight F to e seven
Knights to h4 Knight to e5 now Queen to
c2 Knight captures on d5 Bishop captures
on d5 and Bishop to e6 and this is where
the game really starts by playing Bishop
to e6 mama kinda seems to have dropped
this b7 pawn but you'll see that this
pawn is extremely poisonous and if 11
captured it for example Bishop captures
on b7 rook to b8 Bishop to d5 now g5
forcing the knight back and if nice to
f5 then Bishop captures on d5 and after
C capture Sun d5 Knight to f3 winning
the exchange here and in this position
after g5 if the knight goes to f3 sorry
if the knight goes to f3 then Bishop
captures on d5 Knight captures on e5 and
to be seven the night is still attacked
and after a move like Knight to d3 Queen
to f6 and it would be very hard for for
whites to play this why doesn't have a
light square bishop this is a this is
the strongest piece in the game the
Queen is threatening to come to f3 the
light squares are terrible here so as it
seems after this Bishop to e6 move this
pawn is indeed poisonous so 11 of course
doesn't capture the pawn he plays rook
to d1 we have Queen to d7 now protecting
the b7 pawn and rook the b1 and this is
where the game gets really interesting
probably rook to e8 and the black can
simply continue playing this even with a
move like Bishop captures on d5 seek
after Sun d5 and Bishop to f6 forcing
this knife to decide where it's gonna go
it can't go to f3 you don't really want
to allow this Bishop to capture the
night opening up the White King so
there's really not a lot of moves or
white and play here if you play Knight
to g2 then nice v recheck of course is
very unpleasant for white so probably a
move like f4 would have to be played and
already you can see that the White King
is definitely feeling the draft so after
rook to be one mommy general decided not
to go for any of this and he played a
most interesting move he played b5 and
this is interesting because well we're
usually used to our onion being the one
that gives up the exchange sacrifice as
you probably remember his games against
Algeria and Magnus Carlsen where he
totally annihilated them with an early
exchange sacrifice so what's the best
move here well probably to capture the
rook which Arnon did my my my suspicious
engine is suggesting the seek after some
b5 but okay a human would definitely
capture the rock so Bishop captures an
a8 rook captures an a8 + f4 Knight
captures on c4
okay mama dro is down the exchange but
he he does have a beautiful bishop
prepare this pawn chain is very strong
the night and c4 is very strong
definitely the compensation is there b3
kicking the night away with tempo and
preparing Bishop to b2 to exchange the
strong dark square Bishop and g7 night
to b6 Bishop to b2 and Bishop capture
some b2 rook captures and rook to e8 e
for and here our onion is threatening f5
and if Mammadov played a move like
Bishop to g4 with a temple on the rook
for example rook to e1 and now Queen to
c6 pressuring the e4 pawn moves like c4
are in the air if this e for pawn ever
lunges forward this this long diagonal
is open the knight is ready to jump into
the game this would have been at least
equal for black but after E for mama dro
didn't go for Bishop to g4 he played
Queen to c6 and he gave Levin the upper
hand and of course xi immediately seized
it with f5 Bishop to c8 now Queen to b3
attacking the d6 pawn and the mama D ro
responds with c4 iron and of course
continues with the best move twin
capture son b6 Queen captures only for
now and rook to f2 not allowing this
pawn to be captured and preparing rook D
to F 1 if needed
for example if mama D Arab decided to go
for a bold move like c3 this might have
been an option but after something like
F captures and F captures rook d2 f1
White's rooks on DF file are looking
very nice here so he decided not to go
for something like this after rook to F
to G captures an f5 was played and all
night the g2 Queen to e5 my monado is
now up to pawns and he would like to
exchange Queens but Aragon refuses this
Queen to h6 although accepting the Queen
trade would also be in White's favor but
Queen to h6 is
better move the black king is definitely
feeling the draft white rate Queen's
Queen to e6 again offering a trade of
Queens
Queen to g5 would check Queen to g6
again offering the trade Queen to h4 and
alkene to g7 Knight to f4 now at a tempo
on the Queen Queen to g4 offering a
trade of Queens and knights to h5 with
check King to h7 a king to h6 and not
only now that 11 feels that it's
definitely in his favor he does straight
Queens Queen captures on g4f characters
and g4 and now Knight to f6 rook to e5
be captures on c4 b captures on c4 and
mama D ro does have a passed pawn now
but it will be very hard for him to find
the time to actually push it
rook to f4 rook to e2 trying to cut off
the king and from coming into the game
and also pressuring the a to pawn and
the H to pawn if the King moves Knight
to g4 would check King to g7 and now
Knight to f6
the rock is guarding the knight on f6
lemon is preparing room d8 and rook g8
rook the e5 now rock to d8
by onion and at Bishop to f5 and this
Bishop to a5 was a must move because if
you play a bold move like c3 here you're
getting check mated with rook to g8
check King to h6
and rook to h4 will check you have to
block this check rope to h5 and rook
captures on h5 this is checkmate
so unfortunately mama dro doesn't have
time to pull the pawn so wrote the rook
b8 and the bishop to f5 now the rook is
no longer protecting the night but 11
finds a beautiful continuation night to
h5 with check came to h6 and now Rock
the g8 and the knight of course can be
captured if you capture the night you
get to rope to h4 checkmate as so after
rook the g8 Bishop to g6
and here Knight to f6
by our onion rook to e1 would check King
to f2 we have worked to a-1 and here we
have a 11 signature move which ends the
game h4 and in this position momager
resign the game because both of them
know what's going to happen next
just to give you an example mama Dara
can prolong this game for a couple of
moves but after something like rook
captures King to f3 rock a tree check
King g2 rook a to check engage 3 and
there are no more no more checks now now
rook to a5 rope to f3 now not allowing
any rook to a3 checks after this pawn
goes to g4 c3 now g4 and well this black
King can't move what's what's gonna
happen next is that this pawn is going
to G if I would check and mommy tiara
will have to give up this rook for the
pawn so c2 for example
rook will guard the promotion Square
Queen comes into the game rook captures
and now after a couple of checks rook
checks king h2 rook checks king g1 rook
will have to go to a5 and it's it's all
over g5 would check the King has nowhere
to go
the rook must be sacrificed rook
captures pawn capture Sanji I would
check the King has the capture and now
Knight captures an 87 he even loses
another pawn the bishop is pinned he
cannot capture the night it's all over
but it's it's very nice that lemon and
it ended this game with his signature
move that is h4 although in his in his
games usually plays as much sooner but
nevertheless so yeah I really enjoyed
this game and I really enjoyed that idea
by mama D ro that b5 idea sacrificing
tha exchange for the strong bishop pair
and that very nice pawn chain and if he
continued with that Bishop to g4 move if
you probably she probably could have
played this game to some advantage and
I'm interested
is this b5 idea home preparation or was
it just some great inspiration over the
board which would be very interesting
because you know it's it's a team match
you're not just playing for herself and
it was a it was a big game for mommy
Jarvis he's playing World Number two
eleven Oregon so I guess he probably
wanted to prove something and it
backfired unfortunately but like I said
I I showed this game because of how well
mommy dro lost the game so I do hope you
enjoyed it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and I will see you soon